hello ladies and gentlemans tim ferriss  one of the things that annoys me is  making hard-boiled eggs that work  they're a pain in the ass to peel so  with the hat tip to dr. Michael EADS I  did some research and number one you  boil them at a slow boil for about 12  minutes with about two inches of water  above the eggs then you cool them throw  some ice in this is key when you put the  water in you put in a teaspoon of baking  soda this raises the pH and reduces  adhering so this is how you peel a  hard-boiled egg without peeling them  which is by far the most annoying part  of the process and what keeps me from  doing it so you like this like that a  little bit off like that the other side  off then you hold it and you just blow  you got you get the egg with no peeling  involved yay that's